there's four distinct positions you can
have in any Market you can have bargain
which is the absolute cheapest one the
next is best value the third position
the marketplace is premium and then the
fourth position in the marketplace is
luxury where the price has no cap part
of the value of the product itself is
the cost that people know you paid to
get it it's where people associate their
status with the purchase they made and
what an amazing position to be I just
raise my prices even more and people
want to buy more and so there's called
veblin Goods in economics they actually
defy the supply demand curve rules
because typically when you raise prices
you decrease volume but in luxury goods
when you raise prices you increase how
many you sell